direction la côte d'ivoire avec son
retour annoncé de l'ex président laurent
gbagbo ancien chef de l'état créé son
propre mouvement politique et rompt
définitivement avec son ancien parti le
front populaire ivoirien le congrès
constitutif de ce nouveau parti se
tiendra les 16 et 17 octobre prochains
et à une semaine de l'événement les
organisateurs elle s'active à abidjan la
précision de notre reporter sur place si
la femme ouzou
laurent gbagbo est de retour quatre mois
exactement après avoir posé le pied sur
le sol ivoirien il s'apprête à présenter
son nouveau mouvement pour l'opposition
c'est en tournant la naissance de ce
parti pourrait replacer l'ancien
président au centre du jeu politique
ivoirien un rassemblement solennel et
officiel à l'hôtel ivoire est une fête
dans le quartier blockhaus ont les
partisans de laurent gbagbo pourront se
retrouver son ancien ministre de la
réconciliation nationale sébastien
djédjé dano participe à l'aventuré nos
espoirs avec ce nouveau parti
c'est de permettre aux ivoiriens aux
africains j'ai la crainte dans un
mouvement de lutte politique qui
respecte la démocratie les droits de
l'homme la solidarité la souveraineté et
les panafricanistes
c'est ça qui est notre espoir laurent
gbagbo qui investit moins de buts pour
buts politiques pour la côte d'ivoire et
pour l'afrique on les cadre de ce
congrès c'est un mouvement qui est lancé
et chacun est libre de s'y joindre à son
rythme mais une interrogation subsiste
l'ex première dame simone gbagbo dont
l'ancien président s'est récemment
séparée sera t-elle présentent lé cadre
de ce nouveau parti affirme qu'elle a
été invité mais celle qui a cofondé le
front populaire ivoirien a fait savoir
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas jouer un
second rôle et elle pourrait refuser
d'afficher un soutien à son ex mari un
an après la réélection d'alassane
ouattara à la présidence de la
république de côte d'ivoire ce congrès
semble marquer une nouvelle étape dans
la recomposition politique qui semble
s'opérer dans le pays depuis le retour
de laurent gbagbo